why would they not want to call me Dr Oz  everyone knows I'm Dr Oz but they don't  think it's the right thing to do they  think it gives me an unfair Advantage so  that is that really is very interesting  and you know Rand Paul is a doctor  Senator Rand Paul he's an  ophthalmologist  um he was not referred to as Dr Rand  Paul during his campaign uh it was Rand  Paul  ophthalmologist from Kentucky okay  totally reasonable the difference here  is that for Mehmet Oz Dr Oz is actually  his his cultural identity it's more than  his profession and in fact when we say  Dr Oz is running we're not saying the  guy we know as a surgeon Dr Oz is  running we're saying Dr Oz the figure  from The Dr Oz Show but the truth is  it's Mehmet Oz who's a doctor it's his  personality it's his celebrity built  around the character Dr Oz that is why  we know who the guy is who is Mehmet Oz  a lot of people wouldn't even know